a representative for louis c.k says the
comedian will issue a statement soon in
response to sexual harassment
allegations the Emmy winner was
scheduled to appear last night on The
Late Show with Stephen Colbert to
promote his new movie that didn't happen
in Colbert told his audience why also
for those of you tuning in to see my
interview with louis c.k tonight i have
some bad news then I have some really
bad news
Louis canceled his appearance here
tonight because the New York Times broke
this story today five women are accusing
louis c.k of sexual misconduct and a
warning some of the allegations are
quite graphic three women interviewed by
the New York Times including one who
wanted to remain anonymous claimed that
louis c.k exposed himself and
masturbated in front of them another
woman said it happened over the phone a
fifth woman said CK approached her and
she declined New York Times culture
reporter milena Raisa joins us at the
table she is one of the journalists who
broke the story of the allegations
against louis c.k good morning to you
good morning you would just never think
you'd be talking about masturbation on
morning TV but here we are this stuff is
very serious
absolutely what made you and your team
decide to investigate him in the first
place well you know this is a moment in
the aftermath of all of this reporting
that people have done about allegations
against Harvey Weinstein Bill O'Reilly
other people in the in the in the news
this is a moment when women feel that
there's a opportunity for solidarity to
speak out and we have had a tips line
newyorktimes.com slash tips in which
people are offering to share their
stories it's been very active so we
started to hear certain names pop up
over and over and we began looking into
them you reached out to the women and
why did what did they tell you why are
they deciding now that is the time to
talk and some of their allegations are
very graphic
they said they brought it up years ago
yeah some of these stories have been out
there you know they've been rumored in
the comedy community especially but I
think for these women for the women we
spoke to they felt that this is the
moment to speak you know there is this
movement there is this sense of
solidarity that their stories now will
get support will be heard will be
listened to in a way that they felt may
not have been happening you know years
what also the bluee KCK reached out to
apologize to some of them at some point
that's right several of the women did
receive
messages from him or spoke to him on the
phone and he expressed feeling sorry for
that his behavior and in some cases when
some of the people accepted his apology
and forgave him but you know one of the
things that's interesting about this
behavior is that it really hits deeply
and an apology is a great move to make
but but it doesn't necessarily erase the
the pain or the trauma of the original
experience was it more difficult for
these women to come forward given the
industry that they're in and their roles
as comedians I mean we look back at his
work and he sort of alluded to these
types of acts before did these women
feel extra pressure about not coming
forward because of the line of work that
they're in I think so I mean comedy like
many fields is a male-dominated industry
and there's an expectation especially if
you're a comedian a female comedian that
you know you can hang with it you can
take a dirty joke you can be accepting
of some raunch that would be out of
place in most workplaces to be honest
point he would sometimes joke about some
of these acts that he some of these
incidents that he's accused of now well
something like masturbation is
definitely a theme and his work you know
he talks makes jokes about it on stage
he makes jokes about it in his TV show
if it factors in his new movie that is
due to be released next week so
definitely some of the women we spoke to
thought that maybe his style of comedy
was perhaps a way to mask the actual
misc like a shield alleged misconduct
yeah he's going to respond in him
statements
yeah we've been told that he is going to
respond in a same and he did not comment
for our story I was struck by something
that Jody Kanter said in our piece
earlier in the show when she said these
women are coming forward now because
they didn't want to miss the window is
there fear that that window is gonna
close and that these types of incidents
are gonna start recurring even after
everything we've seen following Harvey
Weinstein revelations I think there is
certainly a fear that there could be a
backlash to all of this information but
you know what we've seen so far and I
can say from our reporting from the
story coming out yesterday to today we
definitely have had other people call up
and say you know I've had experiences in
general not necessarily with Louie but
you know people feel like this is the
moment to talk and it's embalming a lot
of people that might not have wanted to
talk before on this tipline are you
investigating other people I'll say that
the tip line has been
active yeah yeah they never want a New
York Times headline saying a story is
coming no Lee no you don't know
certainly not this one thank you very
much Melina thank you